j'ai lu beaucoup de l'adarth 71,14 razza
il est la pierre angulaire vous avez
propre au québec
[Musique]
il fait partie du paysage musical depuis
plus de 30 ans au québec les pistes de
danse n'ont plus aucun secret pour
didier chocottes qui a 47 ans est
toujours aussi passionné par la musique
mais combien des gens sont monde a
basculé en mars 2020 je pensais que ça
allait durer deux semaines vous avouer
je livrais m'habiller priest une bonne
de ce mets la maison les enfants eux
mais les semaines se sont transformées
en moi rapidement il a investi pour
réaménager son sous sol pour continuer à
partager son amour de la musique
bien que je me musique par puis-je mais
la première tonne mais la deuxième je
suis même plus présents dans la réalité
qu'on appelle coved ou distanciation je
le vis pu je comprends je suis libre
dans ma musique puis je sais que sait on
de la boîte un des gens et ça marche
[Applaudissements]
chaque semaine il réussit à faire danser
des milliers de personnes confinées en
mixant en direct devant son écran
allez je vois la délivrance à force de
voir la délivrance ça veut dire qu'il ya
une crise fake ou je la vois est
directement comment était votre journée
mesdames et messieurs une toute autre
réalité une piste de danse virtuel qui
fait du bien j'ai envie qu'ils
m'arrêtent à l'épicerie qui fait été
live comme toute ma maison on est on
écoute sans capote
ça me suit partout le suisse cédait
s'attendait quand et comment ces noms b
pau pour que ça me suivent à l'épicerie
tu peux pas de thann et de faire du bien
tout petit peu tannique que quelque
chose qui redondant mais de faire du
bief moi c'est ce moi ça me nourrit
moi je pense que danser c'est le plus
beau remède c'est à besoin d'être je
pense que tout le monde
cette flamme note un rendez vous
hebdomadaire qui ne manque jamais depuis
un an
moi ma - dennis était de pouvoir exercer
le mont échange c'est comme si j'avais
trouvé mon canal il a maintenant une
nouvelle partenaire sa fille
maïssa - demoiselles et la meuse ou
chelsea
moi ma vie présentement à peut pas être
plus vrai qu'elle lui présente bientôt
ma fille ne peut pas être plus présente
qu'à l'est présentement dans la vie
mungo peut pas être plus présent
l'absence de mes enfants quand qu'ils
sont ne peut pas être plus absent je
vous ai tout est juste plus vrai qu une
soirée à la fois une chanson à la fois
c'est par la musique qu'il réussit à
voir la lumière au bout du tunnel
[Musique]
ici marie michèle osant radio canada
montréal
[Musique]